FIRST PLACE.
.
>> WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED THIS
WEEK?
THE MEDIA SUCKS.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS TODAY'S ANGLE.
I THINK OF THE COVINGTON STORY
WE REALIZED ONCE AGAIN THE
MEDIA WILL USE ANYTHING THEY
CAN AND THEN UNLESS UNCHECKED
THEY WOULD NOT STOP IF NOT FOR
HONEST EYEWITNESSES THEY WOULD
NOT GO INTO THE LA BREA TAR
PITS THEY EMBRACED IT FROM A
SKETCHY SOURCE AND PUSHED OUT
LIKE CHEAP MATH SO THEY WERE
THE MEDIA APPROVED EVIL WHEN
THEY WERE CAUGHT PUSHING THE
WHY THEY BLAMED EVERYONE BUT
THEMSELVES.
BUT THANKS TO NBC'S SAVANNAH
GUTHRIE WE CAN SEE IT IN ALL
ITS GLORY BY COMPARING HER
QUESTIONS TO THE ONES THAT SHE
ASKED THE NATIVE AMERICAN
NATHAN PHILLIPS.
>> DO YOU OWE ANYBODY AN
APOLOGY?
DO YOU SEE YOUR OWN FAULT IN
ANY WAY?
WE MY FIRST QUESTION.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
DO THINK IT WAS A GOOD IDEA TO
START CHANTING BACK
?-QUESTION-MARK IT HAS BEEN A
WHIRLWIND FEW DAYS FOR YOU ON
THE FRONT PAGE OF EVERY
NEWSPAPER.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
.
>> YOU CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN
THROUGH A LOT THESE LAST FEW
DAYS BUT SOME PEOPLE SEE YOU
AS A YOUNG KID WITH A SMIRK ON
HIS FACE.
DO YOU THINK YOU SHOULD HAVE
APOLOGIZED?
DO YOU THINK IF YOU ARE NOT
WEARING THAT HAT THIS MIGHT
NOT HAVE HAPPENED?
HAVE YOU FEARED FOR YOUR
SAFETY SINCE ALL OF THIS HAS
HAPPENED?
THERE IS SOMETHING ABOUT
STANDING YOUR GROUND.
>> TALK ABOUT A CONTRAST.
IT REMINDS ME OF THESE TWO.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: THANKS TO SAVANNA I DO
KNOW THAT THAT IS A SIGN OF
AGGRESSION DOES SHE THINK THIS
IS ALSO AGGRESSIVE?
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS TERRIFYING.
HOW ABOUT THIS?
.
>> I GUESS THAT IS KIND OF
AGGRESSIVE.
WATCHING THE MEDIA COVER THE
COVINGTON FIASCO IS LIKE A
CONTESTANT WITH HER OWN BEAUTY
PAGEANT.
NOW THE STORY THE MANAGER THE
MAGICALLY GOES AWAY SO REMIND
YOU OF WHAT'S POSSIBLE TO MAKE
SURE THEY ARE PROPERLY ALIGNED
THEY ARE LIARS AND JERKS THAT
IS IT FOR NOW.
[APPLAUSE]
THESE TWO LOSS ONE - - ALYSSA
MILANO AND KATHY GRIFFIN WITH
THEIR DROOLING HATE AND
COMPASSION THEY LED THE CHARGE
BRANDING THEM RACIST WHY DO WE
LET FAME EXCUSE PEOPLE FOR
BEING T20?
THE PLAGUE IS FAMOUS AND WE
DON'T ADMIRE THAT.
BUT THEN ON THE STATUS TO
EXCUSE THEIR OWN JERKINESS
MUTTERING.
THE THIRD CULPRIT IS TWITTER.
IN THE TRACTION MACHINE WITH
FACE-TO-FACE CONTACT PLATFORM
WHERE ANTAGONISM IS ITS OWN
REWARD AND LET'S NOT FORGET.
[BLEEP]
THIS WAS BROUGHT TO YOU BY
IDENTITY POLITICS IT IS A
POWER STRUGGLE BETWEEN THE
OPPRESSOR AND THE RULES ARE
DICTATED BY THE ENTERTAINMENT
COMPLEX AND THE CRACKPOT
CULPRITS WHO ACCOSTED THE
TEENS?
THEY ARE DELIGHTFULLY
ECCENTRIC.
THE FINAL CULPRIT IS YOUR OWN
EYES PERK YOU CANNOT TRUST
THEM VIRAL VIDEOS ARE DESIGNED
TO TRICK THEM THEY ARE CALLED
VIRAL FOR A REASON THEY ARE
HIGHLY CONTAGIOUS AND WILL
MAKE YOU PUKE I INITIALLY FELL
FOR THE WRONG EVENT BY
TRUSTING MY OWN BEAUTIFUL BLUE
EYES.
I WAS FOOLED AND I AM NEVER
FOOLED NEVER RUSH TO JUDGE YES
I WAS AT BRUNCH AT THE TIME
BUT NO EXCUSES.
BUT IF I CAN FALL FOR THIS
THEN WE ALL CAN.
THE BEST BET IS IF IT SHOWS UP
ON SOCIAL MEDIA RUN LIKE HELL.
TO THE SAFEST SPACE YOU CAN
FIND IS THERE ONE PLACE WE CAN
UNTIL THIS ALL BLOWS OVER?
.
>>.
>> CONTROVERSY CAN ERUPT AT
ANY MOMENT.
>> WHEN OUTRAGE STRIKES CAN
YOU KEEP YOUR FAMILY SANE?
.
>> WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> THERE IS NO TIME.
GET THE KIDS.
.
>> QUICK.
>> OPEN THE DOOR.
IT'S TOO LATE.
IF WE OPEN THE DOOR NOW WE ARE
SUCKED INTO THE OUTRAGE FOR
TAX.
.
>> WE CAN JUST WAIT IT OUT IN
THE OUTRAGE BUNKER.
>> A SELF-RIGHTEOUS DIATRIBE.
AND ALL THAT COMES WITH
SENSATIONALIZE BREAKING NEWS
STORIES.
AND THEN YOU CAN COME OUT AND
ENJOY LIFE AND SEE AS IF IT
NEVER HAPPENED.
>> WE MADE IT.
[LAUGHTER]
.
>> HOLY MOTHER OF GOD.